[Música]
por espacio de 4 horas el presidente de
perú pedro castillo rindió una
declaración ante la fiscalía de la
nación el mandatario cumplió con esta
cita como parte de una investigación
preliminar por un supuesto caso de
corrupción así yo llamo a los peruanos a
tener confianza en él como mandatario
todo listo en colombia para la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales que se
llevarán a cabo el domingo observadores
de 33 países acompañaran la jornada
según las autoridades electorales sólo
hasta el próximo miércoles se conocerá
oficialmente al ganador de los comicios
europa se enfrenta a una ola de calor
que ha encendido las alarmas antes de
iniciar el verano reino unido francia y
españa están entre las naciones que han
registrado las altas temperaturas que se
espera continúen durante los próximos
días
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en perú
durante 4 horas estuvo el presidente
pedro castillo rindiendo declaración
ante la fiscalía de la nación como parte
de una investigación preliminar que
avanza por un presunto caso de
corrupción a través de un comunicado de
la fiscalía indicó que hay indicios de
hechos presuntamente delictivos por su
parte el mandatario pidió tener
confianza en él y en la justicia
el presidente de perú da la cara ante la
justicia a pedro castillo se le acusa de
ser líder de una presunta conspiración
criminal que recibió sobornos por
contratos de obras públicas su
comparecencia ante la fiscalía se dio a
pesar de la solicitud de su defensa para
que se anulara cualquier investigación
en su contra asegurando que el
mandatario goza de inmunidad absoluta
mientras ejerce como presidente casi yo
le dijo al pueblo peruano que es
inocente y que se presenta al poder
judicial sólo para aclarar la situación
a pesar de los obstáculos de mentiras y
señalamientos pido a los peruanos
confianza en que todos los objetivos
planteados por el gobierno el pueblo se
harán realidad trabajando juntos porque
el perú está por encima de cualquier
circunstancia
a parte del mandatario la fiscalía ha
extendido la investigación a otros
funcionarios públicos castillo ha
sobrevivido a dos intentos de
destitución en el congreso lo que
refleja la inestabilidad política
peruana desde 2016 con cinco presidentes
distintos desde entonces y al menos tres
disoluciones del congreso el señor es
una
comprobada
de horas
de
tiempo a pesar de que la primera vez en
la historia reciente de perú que un
presidente es investigado durante su
gestión entre 1985 y 2020 seis
presidentes peruanos han enfrentado
acusaciones de corrupción
en colombia las autoridades ultiman
detalles para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales que se
realizará el domingo 19 de junio gustavo
petro y rodolfo hernández se miden ante
más de 39 millones de colombianos
habilitados para votar en más de 12.000
puestos tanto dentro del país como en el
exterior
previamente hablamos con carlos coronel
ex registrador delegado en lo electoral
en colombia y docente de la facultad de
derecho de la universidad javeriana que
nos explicó si hay confianza en el
sistema electoral colombiano luego de lo
ocurrido en las legislativas de marzo en
las que hubo irregularidades en el
conteo de votos con lo que tengo una una
muy sólida tradición democrática como
tal en la conservación de sus
instituciones y también de la mano de un
excelente trabajo de un organismo
electoral desde el año 1990 es
independiente a las ramas del poder
público
es de todos conocimientos ha sido de
todos de público conocimiento las
dificultades importantes nuevas en las
elecciones del congreso pero no obstante
lo anterior tal como se vio en la
primera vuelta y estamos seguros se va a
demostrar la fortaleza de la
institucionalidad colombiana en este
próximo domingo le brindarán a todos los
actores y a la ciudadanía y al país y al
mundo en general una unas elecciones que
estoy seguro van a hacer ejemplares
donde se van a ratificar vuelvo y repito
la fortaleza el sistema como tal
independiente los ajustes que tuvieron
que hacerse para brindar un voto de
confianza en este caso en manos del
árbitro que es el proceso electoral ese
sería un mensaje claro desde la academia
que lo observó así y estoy seguro que
así será
los invitamos este domingo a conectarse
con el especial que tenemos preparado
aquí en france 24 para la segunda vuelta
de las presidenciales colombianas andrés
meza los estará acompañando con el
análisis de nuestros invitados y
periodistas en el lugar de la noticia
la crisis económica sin precedentes en
cuba' llevó a muchos habitantes a
abandonar su país según los datos del
servicio de aduanas y protección de
fronteras de eeuu 140.000 ciudadanos
cubanos han llegado al país
norteamericano desde el pasado mes de
octubre otros intentan conseguir una
visa en países latinoamericanos como
panamá méxico o colombia que se
convierten en sus puntos de partida para
intentar llegar a estados unidos pero
los requerimientos para obtener los
visados son cada vez más rigurosos
muchos cubanos como danny si su hija
esperen durante horas oa veces meses
para entrar en la embajada en medio de
una fuerte crisis económica en la isla
los habitantes intentan obtener vistas
de los países vecinos con la esperanza
de llegar a eeuu pero el costo de las
citas en las embajadas y los nuevos
requisitos dificultan el proceso la
están vendiendo su casa todos sus vienen
para entonces ir a buscar en busca de
otra otra oportunidad
el riesgo para la vida es inevitable
entonces por esa vida esta es la vía que
debes debe ser con la correcta debe ser
la que todos deberíamos tener derecho a
pasar por está bien no arriesgar sus
vidas
los cubanos culpan a los eeuu de
alimentar la inmigración ilegal al
mantener el embargo económico de la
época de la guerra fría y cortar los
servicios consulares en la habana
en arkansas debemos dar la bienvenida al
tan esperado restablecimiento de los
servicios consulares en la embajada de
eeuu en la habana para abrir de nuevo
los canales de inmigración legal
consiguiendo presión obscura govern pero
hay que tener en cuenta que el número de
visados legales que los estados unidos
pueden ofrecer comparado con la demanda
es una cantidad insignificante
la semana pasada en la cumbre de las
américas donde los representantes del
gobierno cubano fueron excluidos los
eeuu acordaron facilitar vías legales
para los inmigrantes washington reanudó
la tramitación de visas en la habana en
mayo y pretende expedir 20.000 visas de
inmigrante a cubanos al año
la comisión europea recomendó otorgarle
a ucrania el estatus de país candidato
para unirse a la unión europea se trata
del primer paso de un largo proceso de
incorporación que exige un amplio
paquete de reformas para el estado de
ucrania que le pide ajustarse a los
estándares europeos en materia de
derechos humanos política educación en
salud y economía para así poder
convertirse en un miembro oficial del
bloque comunitario estas fueron las
palabras del mandatario ucraniano
volodymyr selenski haciendo referencia a
la recomendación de la comisión de
poderes de audio
por estamos a un paso del comienzo de
plena integración en la unión europea
tenemos una conclusión positiva de la
comisión europea sobre la candidatura de
ucrania este es un logro histórico para
todos aquellos que trabajan para nuestro
estado sólo queda esperar la decisión
del consejo europeo la próxima semana
que se diseña y ebro país grande
nocturno tis europa vive una intensa ola
de calor y las playas se convirtieron en
un sitio infalible para mitigar las
altas temperaturas mientras que la
sombra de los parques y las fuentes son
muy codiciadas en españa el riesgo de
incendios forestales es extremo en casi
todo el país el informe de rafael p
sombra hidratación y poca ropa son los
remedios que los europeos se encuentran
en medio de la ola de calor que afecta
el viejo continente en el reino unido
los termómetros marcaron el día más
cálido del año hasta ahora con 34 grados
centígrados allí y centenares de
personas salieron a las playas para
mitigar los efectos de las altas
temperaturas
nacionales y turistas son conscientes de
las causas de ese fenómeno meteorológico
está lloviendo y estoy en londres y
estoy viviendo aquí así que algo debe
cambiar necesitamos tomar precauciones
sobre el cambio climático más temprano
que tarde porque sin duda es preocupante
para todos nosotros ahora lo estamos
disfrutando pero a largo plazo podríamos
sacrificarnos por gone turn
micrófono y might sacrifice en francia
se vive en temperaturas récord en
burdeos los 39 grados reinantes hacen
que las sombras y las fuentes adquieran
un valor incalculable los parques
albergan personas semidesnudas que
disfrutan de la frescura de esos sitios
y
durante el día voy a los museos a los
jardines a todos los centros comerciales
cualquier cosa para refrescar mis ideas
y me tomo mi tiempo para no pasar
demasiado calor pero por la noche donde
estoy es bajo techo y es insoportable
en españa las temperaturas han alcanzado
los 43 grados lo que hace que aumente el
riesgo de incendios forestales
cataluña ha perdido más de 500 hectáreas
de bosque producto de las llamas cerca
de baldomar en casi todo el país el
riesgo de fuego es extremo según la
agencia estatal de metereología así
concluimos esta misión de noticias a
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía y
les invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que volvemos en breve
[Música]